all right let's get to uh two stories
that are just um
there it's not beyond parody they they
seem almost beyond reality but
unfortunately they are very very real
remember back on january 6th when the
trump rioters who are trump supporters
presumably because they're there writing
for trump to remain president started
chanting hang mike pence and of course
hang mike pence was related to
mike pence being
asked to
being by some expected to do
something even though it's not exactly
clear what he could do he couldn't
actually do anything
um to delay
the counting of the votes on january 6th
in congress
donald trump in a now revealed interview
with abc reporter jonathan carl which is
being released as part of the release of
jonathan carl's new book we have audio
we're going to play it for you
uh donald trump defends his supporters
chanting hang mike pence saying listen
pence was safe he wasn't actually in
danger
and the supporters were right to be
angry because the election was stolen
again going to the previous reports that
trump was furious with pence demanding
pence do something to keep him in office
which pence couldn't do
so again another story verified um let's
go to the audio here is the interview
from march of uh this year take a listen
to this were you worried about him
during that siege
were you worried about no i thought he
was well protected and i i had heard
that he was in good shape
no because uh i had heard he was in very
good shape
but
but no he heard those chants that was
terrible he was you know the
he could have oh the people were very
angry
so jonathan carl says the hat the chance
the hang mike pence was terrible and
trump says well people were angry
and that they were legitimately angry
because
it's common sense john it's common sense
that
you're supposed to protect how can you
if you know a vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
so there's like
three different things there first of
all
notice how they mention common sense
when they can't really give you
empirical reasoning or data to justif
it's common sense it's common sense when
i was in a jury room thinking back to
you know all these trials we've been
covering when i was in the jury room and
we were supposed to decide whether
something was self-defense on the basis
of the way the law was written
four
two to four of the six jurors insisted
it's common sense it was self-defense
rather than what does the law say so
commons common sense comes out often
when they can't actually explain their
positions um and then again how can if
you know a vote is fraudulent trump says
how can you pass a fraudulent vote onto
congress
whatever your belief about that which
trump never demonstrated there was
anything fraudulent whatever your belief
about that is
pence did not have the ability or
authority
to prevent the election from being
certified for joe biden common sense
would be
trump is on trial in multiple
jurisdictions that would be common sense
here so then basically just as
interestingly
this is crazy what trump is saying he's
he's defending the chance of hang mike
pence because the anger at pence was
legitimate as trump sees it and pence
was safe
per trump's opinion on that
the question is brought to republican
senator john barrasso
and he's given the opportunity to
criticize donald trump's defense of the
chance of hang mike pence and barrasso
doesn't do it if you need another signal
about whether the republican elected
officials are still standing in line
behind donald trump uh
and and um uh
supportive at least publicly of trump
it's this take a look at this he's given
the opportunity to criticize trump for
this and he doesn't finally i want to
ask you about president trump as you
know john carl our chief washington
correspondent had an interview with
president trump be released this week
where the president seems to defend
those who are saying hang mike pence on
january 6th you want to show it
does were you worried about him during
that siege
were you worried about no i thought he
was well protected and i i had heard
that he was in good shape no you heard
those chants that was terrible he was
you know the
he could have well the people were very
angry they're saying because it's it's
common sense how can you if you know a
vote is fraudulent
right how can you pass on a fraudulent
vote
to congress
so he says hang mike pence is common
sense
can your party tolerate a leader who
defends murderous chance against his own
vice president
well
well let me just say the republican
party is incredibly united right now and
it's because of the policies like
administration and i think the more that
the so first response is to say this
administration is bad bidens and so it's
united the party democrats and the press
becomes obsessed with president trump i
think the better it is for the
republican party president trump brings
lots of energy to the party he's raised
force elections are about the future not
the past and that's what we saw in
virginia and all across the country and
the republican policies and the trump
policies of a strong economy and
american energy not begging vladimir
putin to produce more oil which is what
joe biden is doing
remember the question is
is it a problem
that
trump is saying
it's okay to say hang mike pence and so
far we've got no answer from john
barrasso
those are policies that we're going to
continue to run on in the future so you
have no problem with the president
saying uh hang mike pence as common
sense
i was with mike pence in the senate
chamber
during january 6th and what happened was
they quickly got vice president pence
out of there certainly a lot he's
basically saying the same thing pence
wasn't really in danger so it's okay
it's not a big deal faster than they
removed the senators i believed he was
safe the whole time
i didn't hear any of those chants i
don't believe that he did either and
vice president pence came back
into the chamber that night and so
there's no so he's not even accepting
that the chance took place which is
fascinating so listen that is really
something else and remember that no
republicans disputed the results of
their votes on the same ballot you had a
bunch of senators and then the trump
biden election the same people saying
the trump biden ballot count can't be
trusted said nothing about their
election count uh only trump the voting
process was legitimate other than trump
biden they only messed with those
ballots these people are disingenuous
they don't actually believe it but they
are unwilling unwilling
to actually criticize donald trump and
much of the reason is trump still has
power at least for now
trump may continue to have power beyond
2022 trump may be the nominee in 2024
and trump may be
maybe president again and none of them
are willing to call him out even when he
says well
it made sense that the people were mad
and pence was safe so hang mike pence
not really a big deal
is there any example from history of a
president
not denouncing chance from his own
followers
to hang the vice president are there
even examples from history of a
president whose followers chanted hang
the vice president and now that i'm
aware of not that i'm aware of
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20
off monk packs keto nut and seed bars
which taste just like your favorite
sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb
and if you just want a low sugar snack i
love the monk pack nut and seed bars
great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance monk pack
nut and seed bars become your favorite
go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout